what's up TD how are you something or
read something that you are back in the
studio yes we are in the studio today
well not in the NFL Network studio in
the Rich Eisen show studio and Elsa good
no I'm aware where the studio is rich I
know so we're here okay we have one two
three four five people just in our
studio and then two in the back so we
are we're more than 10 feet away from
each other like Del 2 phone Brock what
are the ones closest to each other so
the gatherings less gathering we're
gathering and the gathering is fewer
than 10 and we're socially distant hmm
we're all feeling good so we're all here
I'm serious about this this is you know
this is serious business man I mean are
your your quarantine with your wife and
kids you got that all set people try to
break the rules try to break the code
try to come in and visit and know like
you just can't come come over to the
house you know but you are above the law
right so how old are your kids now how
old are your kids kids are nine seven
and five yeah we got two old boys and a
little girl who's basically telling
everybody you're not the boss of me is
what's happening is a lot there's a lot
of there's a lot of I guess you know
again thank God we're all healthy and
this is what we're talking about right
but there's a lot of to use the survivor
phrase a lot of travel council meetings
in the Eisen household would Susie
Schuster I'll tell you what I think I
have spent in this much time with my
kids
at the time that you know we travel a
lot you know whether I travel every
weekend it seems like it's not every
week it's how things are to be able to
be around them as much to see their you
know dead online schools are we around
last week when they still work just so
to really see that and see how so what
they're learning
I was pretty cool so and I try to enjoy
the moment while we can and because once
things get back to normal man there's
some times when a father yet with young
kids that we've heard that and now I'm
certainly feeling that yep for sure now
what are you doing with defy I know
that's a sports performance beverage and
wellness company that you co-founded
you've been talking about it what are
you doing right now with defy to raise
some money across the country for people
in need during this crisis hours worth
of product to feed in America and nation
you know their tax right now obviously
what's going on you know nobody can give
give too much at this point so we just
try to do what we can do and settle how
the best way we could and I was to
provide free beverages for over 400 look
at the forty thousand I was over about
ninety something thousand bottles as it
is and you know and we're going to
basically to try to you know just try to
encourage other people man we've seen
people out there doing a tremendous
amount of work and so I think what it
does is it inspires you to do better do
what you can do at this time of crisis
whatever we can do whether it money give
time you know give advice to people be
there for people call or FaceTime
whatever you can do but I think the more
that we all can do are the better I'm
gonna give kudos to shout out to Iraq
you can which is our fulfillment partner
and they're you know this stuff is being
shipped out throughout the United States
and so they're really step it up and
they're paying for all the shipping
concentrate pause there have these
beverages Sinatra feeding America and so
we're like I said man we're just trying
to do what we've been doing and
hopefully and hopefully hopefully that
we inspire people to just kind of do
this
and then I guess while we're on that
subject thank you to the the people who
were trucking this around the country
and moving and shipping things around
the country people who are driving those
trucks and working those jobs to make
sure that stuff like that what Terrell
Davis is trying to rally people around
and with the LA Regional Food Bank the
food bank for New York City the food
bank of the Rockies and Denver Michigan
clean clean a Gleaners community food
bank of southeastern Michigan and then
Chicago Food Depository just some of the
places around nationally that these are
donation locations TD here on the Rich
Eisen show spoke to Melvin Gordon last
hour and he just sounds like a kid who
you know just got chewed up and spit out
by the business of football at the
running back position TD and I know he's
wound up in a good spot and you know
what spot he wound up in the same depth
chart with Philip Lindsey and Denver is
gonna do good things with them and I
want to hit on that in a second but
what's going on with the running back
market these days I'm glad I'm not in
that market man it's definitely down if
you're I guess if you're looking at it
in Europe I guess a GM or a president or
head coach yeah you looked at some of
the examples of the backs were paid and
you look at Todd Gurley it's being one
you look at David Johnson got paid two
years ago you know obviously didn't a
mentor last year but it's I mean it's
more than my it's more the attitude
toward the running back that I'm hearing
from a lot of these clubs that they feel
like debate one guy that kind of money
those days or if they're not gone we're
leaving and they thought they can get a
two credit you know back or occasionally
actually try to have a the equivalent of
production that they have with one guy
and you know you've got the nine and
last year learning better Russian teams
in the league they were able to do it
of course Baltimore over Lamar Jackson
can do it but how no rich is just you
know it seemed like we had this
conversation probably two or three years
ago
then it got better antagonist hard
dragon everybody was getting a look at
that Todd and how you ate params and
it'll get Zika not elevated the Cowboys
and let's bail when he was doing for the
Pittsburgh Steelers then you have this
this year what was Miss bizarre I met I
think I had something where this year
eleven of the top rushers were on the
rookie contracts i eleven of the top 12
so when you see that you're saying well
why do I need to go ahead and get a guy
who's going through the sixth year and
paying the big money when I can give me
a first-round draft running back you
know I happen for four years if I can
franchise or put the fifth year option
on them India five and if I still want
to I can fantasize Packer and so it's
just the attitude of our team's view
behind backs I still think I got like
Derrick Henry I think he still has a lot
of tread on the power and you have to
pay him you got to make him be
highest-paid running back but man when
you lose time early to that contract it
really shrunk the you know nobody got
the franchise tactic it made it worse
it's big and the more contracts they get
shredding up it's gonna bring that
number down even more so so I'm a firm
believer you still need that that that
quality you know star back but that's
not they added to some of these coaches
and GM's so what advice would you give
Derrick Henry right now I mean like you
know he's gonna be in a situation where
they're gonna gonna probably offer him a
long-term contract
and it just depends on what the contract
looks like like his mind I say do I want
a four-year deal with guaranteed money
draw I think that I need to have this
contract for four years or on are
looking at a two or three-year deal I've
been sort of gambling myself to do
another after that and it's got to be
something obviously we're you know give
Robeson in and brave old got a share
like land that this contract is gonna be
star on both sides it's gonna be out for
for both guys for both sides but even
some I like like Henry's man
you understand what the landscape is
like like you know you may feel a
certain way about your skills and that's
who we know you should be a highest-paid
run in fact at this stage but
unfortunately this market may not
dictate that or can I give you the
guarantee you might at you that you're
looking for going forward and I hope I'm
wrong I really hope that he does get
some guaranteed miss so he's not looking
at that kind of me work you know they
release you then you're not going to see
that that money because he certainly
deserves it and they're they're paying
him not only I believe that his better
days are ahead of him too you look back
at his career he kind of started off a
little slow and he's gained some
momentum I think he's gonna get better
TD Terrell Davis Pro Football Hall of
Famer here on the Rich Eisen show how do
you think Melvin Gordon and Phillip
Lindsey gonna look like in the same
offense Melvin Melvin said he did not
ask or know before signing how how it's
gonna look he says he knows what the
offense is but he didn't ask directly
like who's starting how much he's gonna
split up how do you think that's gonna
wind up working in Denver yeah I mean
bring a guy in a sauna for two years do
believe his mom's 60 million I believe
yep you know that tells you that there
and I look at welcome I've watched it in
the last five years and saying it was
last la and I think the Broncos feel
like they can get more out of him and I
think he would agree that he didn't you
know he hadn't won years over a thousand
yards I know you have the two Pro Bowls
you watch him you feel like man there's
more there's something that I've been he
got more than what he's showing you on
the field and I believe that's what
Johnny and we got a man that they feel
like they can they can really maximize
and get the most out of Melvin Gordon
and that you have Phillip Lindsey who's
a different back all together and and
Phillip can he can do everything and I
was what John went back was watching
taping silicon run before the tackle is
he the run on the goal line but I think
he's really exceptional as me you talked
about the sort of dump down the
unplanned streams or
break plea breaks to town and they find
Philip jump off and now he's in open
space and that's where he's really
exciting they would Melvin day of course
you know he's 215 pounds he's gonna be
probably the guy that they use on first
and second down kinda where defense
office you know out between tackles it
got soft hands he can get the ball well
so they think two guys they can
certainly use and I would automatically
male getting in the majority of the
carries or touches and then kind of
being that confident ago I did read some
that Phillip said he's not gonna sit
there you know Rover come in here and
just job he's gonna fight for it and
he's crappy like that so I think people
think that when you say that that you
mean you don't like the person company
and no that's just a competitor he feels
like you bring somebody in and I need to
go ahead and step my game up they make
sure that person doesn't get my job
Terrell Davis here on the Rich Eisen
show there won't be any as we know pro
days or second interviews face to face
we're not gonna have that before the
draft so it's gonna be basically the eye
on the sky scouting from last fall plus
the combine give me the best most Pro
ready running back you think that's
available in this year's draft from what
you seem argue that that cat is not the
most so ready the way he runs I love
Jonathan Taylor I just think you know
you have him swift
you have that worry layer out of
question so you've got some good backs
but I think beyond race we've just
because number one I looked at tread and
he I mean obviously didn't run the ball
and carry the ball a lot enjoy fishing
it's great thing then I was there with
Tony Michelle and big children and he
still was getting some burns even when
those guys went backfield
but I just like his he's got you say the
tools in a toolbox
he's got those and that is can you make
some how do you miss can you create
something out of them are you are you
the passing game can you protect can you
you know are your guys and went on a
defense as the game goes on he's got
boots we've got really good speed when
you want some sometimes you know you
might not think that the elite speed but
he's got good a football speed which I
like it is rather really in 40 time at
the combine does about to say that's
it's it's odd that dad of all that you'd
you just pull out of thin air at Georgia
Bulldog but you also I know and he's
great and I but you also know what it's
like to share time in the backfield in
Georgia right I mean Hines Ward was
right there next year right yeah I took
my job is what most people don't know so
high I fit me did the bench and then
when I came back you know when I kind of
fought my way I guess into the starting
realize they brought me back at a
fullback so I was a fullback in highs
with the tailback and that's how I end
up getting back into the start well it
wasn't even beating Hines out and then
eventually they put me back at halfback
there is an I in Davis but not Terrell I
understand that and and how about that I
mean not many back fields could say that
there were two not one but two Super
Bowl MVPs in it at the same time right
not many plays eavers that want it
certainly when they were transitioning
from running back to wide receivers it's
quite rare I mean before I let you go TD
you know Phillip Lindsey asked for your
number you were gracious to give it to
him so that's a different situation when
there's a number that's out there that
was previously worn by an all-time great
that's grace like you were to say go
ahead and wear it what do you think the
conversation between Godwin and Tom
Brady was that that wound up with Brady
getting Godwin's 12 can you walk me
through what you think happened there
god when made this statement he was like
listen Tom really wants it and I'ma give
it to him I mean like come on and I was
like that
automatic the minute he's chime you knew
he would get number 12 so I don't rich I
don't think that conversation think they
went to conversation at all I don't
think it was yeah but I mean it's not
like God I think Tommy definitely I
think Tom definitely ripped off a few
bills I think it's gonna be a
significant amount of money and you know
is there an actual update on this
subject there is there is Kimberly Jonz
our our friend reported that Chris
Godwin told the Buccaneers website no
transaction he offered it to Tom Brady
Tom Brady accepted it's not like God we
didn't have a transformative gear
wearing the 12 TDS played the last two
years we don't know him associated with
the number 12 like Tom Brady Tom Brady
that number 12 Tom Brady used to know
you can't mix it up all right
you can't mix up that so that's why I'm
saying there was no conversation there's
a man like you know you know what's
about to happen you know Tom Brady's
coming on board right we know what
number he's laying and Chris you're not
12 anymore so let's just keep you some
option or what number you would like to
that I hear you
yeah I'm Plus I guess it's it's written
in the the rule book that a Penn Stater
must have defer to a Michigan guy that's
what it says right here I'm looking at
it right here on my screen there you go
with baby TD thanks for the call
love you man be well with your your
beautiful wife and beautiful family and
let's stay safe together and I can't
wait to you know give you a hug when I
see again right back at you that's
Terrell Davis go to his uh go to his
Twitter feed at Terrell underscore Davis
Instagram at the real Terrell Davis to
learn more again about defi donating
four hundred thousand dollars worth of
products to feeding America in LA New
York Chicago in Detroit and how you
might be able to get involved